en plus d'une conversation privée avec
joe biden loin des caméras
les proches de georgia floride ont
rencontré des législateurs et durera 1
la photo de famille au capitole avec la
présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi fillonistes
floyd a rappelé l'importance de faire
adopter la très attendue réforme qui
vise à lutter contre les violences
policières
parce que comme tu dit diana il va faire
quoi ton peut pas danser la salle yes
changer le monde lui répond la fillette
ce projet de loi prévoit entre autres
d'interdire aux policiers de faire des
prises d'étranglement et de revoir
l'immunité partielle accordée aux
agences ils sont poursuivis au civil
le projet déjà adopté à la chambre des
représentants est en négociation au
sénat
joe biden s'est dit confiant qu'un
déblocage se produira sous peu après la
rencontre avec le président et la
vice-présidente fillonistes floyd a
lancé que si on peut légiférer pour
protéger les oiseaux on peut faire de
même pour les gens de couleur
mais sa soeur à bridget n'était pas du
voyage
aucune raison d'y aller vite elle baille
donne a rompu ses promesses
la loi n'est pas promulguée depuis la
mort de john floyd des dizaines d'afro
américains ont été tués aux mains de la
police
ici et ailleurs au pays les militants
s'indigne d'avoir encore à quémander des
réformes
un an plus tard pas question donc de
relâcher la pression
au minnesota les militants réclament
plusieurs lois par exemple pour avoir le
droit de visionner les films des caméras
corporelle des policiers pour comprendre
ce qui s'est passé question des [ __ ]
habilité d'été cette militante assure
que depuis un an le mouvement black like
the matters est galvanisé à coups de
mobilisation et de coalition entre les
organisations établies comme la sienne
et les plus nouvelles ce qui permet au
mouvement de se faire entendre dans le
dialogue sur les politiques publiques
son avis de nombreux américains connus
ou anonymes se sont agenouillés pendant
presque dix minutes pour rendre hommage
à georges floyd un temps de réflexion
sur le chemin parcouru sur des batailles
à livrer comme les appelle à réduire le
financement de la police une proposition
controversée au moment où la violence
est en recrudescence au pays
ici annick bureaud 1 du canada
minneapolis